Hey everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference, held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Kim Mills was a guest host. We hope you like this episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在2019年10月于华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会（APA）“技术、思维与社会”会议期间录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，
that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm coming to you from APA's annual technology, mind, and society conference in Washington, D.C., a cross-disciplinary meeting to discuss psychology's role in developing and advancing everything from virtual reality to artificial intelligence to the Internet of Things. Have you ever wondered why drivers don't get car sick? And if you've ever been seasick, are you curious to know what causes it and what, if anything, can be done to stave at all? off. Joining me today is Dr. Arnnnnch, a clinical and experimental psychologist from Israel, where he directs Rollnick's Institute for Advanced Psychotherapy and Studies Psychophysiology and the Integration of Technology and Psychology. He spent 20 years as a psychologist in the Israeli Navy, developing various methods to improve sailors' performance and well-being under conditions that tended to make
旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯，现在是在华盛顿特区举行的APA年度“技术、思维与社会”会议现场为您报道。这是一场跨学科会议，旨在讨论心理学在开发和推进从虚拟现实、人工智能到物联网等各个领域中的作用。您是否曾好奇为什么司机不会晕车？如果您曾经晕船，是否想知道是什么原因导致的，以及有什么办法可以预防吗？今天来到节目中的是来自以色列的临床与实验心理学家阿农·罗尔尼克（Arnon Rolnick）博士，他在那里负责罗尔尼克高级心理治疗与研究中心，专注于心理生理学以及技术与心理学的整合。他曾在以色列海军担任心理学家20年，开发了各种方法来改善水手在容易导致
them seasick. He is also working on a book exploring how virtual psychotherapy can open new ways to study the roles of the body and brain in therapy. Welcome, Dr. Rollnick. Thank you very much. Thank you for inviting me. One reason I wanted to talk to you today is to learn more about one of the papers you're presenting at APA's Technology Mind and Society Conference. It's called Technology Made Us Motion Sick.
晕船的环境下的表现和身心健康。他目前正在撰写一本书，探讨虚拟心理治疗如何开辟研究身体和大脑在治疗中作用的新途径。欢迎您，罗尔尼克博士。非常感谢。谢谢您的邀请。我今天想和您交流的一个原因是想更多地了解您在APA“技术、思维与社会”会议上发表的其中一篇论文。它的题目是《技术让我们晕动症》。
Autonomous cars will make us vomit. It's a review of 40 years of research, which is a lot of time to study motion sickness. With the advent of self-driving cars, The idea that these vehicles might make people motion sick is one glitch that hasn't gotten a lot of coverage by the media. So I'm wondering, how much do scientists know at this point about the likelihood that this will be a widespread problem? And what can we do about it? Well, we studied this phenomenon for many years.
自动驾驶汽车会让我们呕吐。这是对40年研究的回顾，研究晕动症的时间跨度很长。随着自动驾驶汽车的出现，这些车辆可能会导致人们晕动症，这是一个尚未受到媒体广泛关注的问题。所以我很好奇，目前科学家们对这成为普遍问题的可能性了解多少？我们又能做些什么呢？嗯，我们研究这种现象已经很多年了。
In fact, this is one of the ancient problem that technology made. you know, we were very happy that we could be moved by cars, ships, and horses, but we were not aware that it will produce such a debilating effect like motion sickness, and not only we found in my work in the Navy that people tend to be even helpless. They feel desperate. and I connected it to Martin Zelligman's theory of flound helplessness. The exposure to uncontrolled motion is producing some sickness. And not only sickness, it produced really some type of depression,
事实上，这是技术带来的古老问题之一。你知道，我们很高兴能通过汽车、轮船和马匹移动，但我们没有意识到这会产生像晕动症这样令人虚弱的影响。而且在我在海军的工作中，我们不仅发现人们往往会感到无助，甚至感到绝望。我将其与马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）的习得性无助理论联系起来。暴露在无法控制的运动中会产生某种疾病。而且不仅是疾病，它确实产生了一些抑郁症，
which I was able to show in my research. So that brought me to the question, how comes that there are certain people who are not sick, like drivers, and that came very nice with the theory that controllability. What learned helplessness theory predict, controllability prevents feeling bad. So I did this study almost 40 years ago, and I was not aware at that time
我在研究中能够证明这一点。这让我产生了一个疑问：为什么有些人不会晕，比如司机？这与可控性理论非常吻合。习得性无助理论预测，可控性可以防止感觉糟糕。所以我大约在40年前做了这项研究，当时我并没有意识到
that in few years from now, everybody will be passenger. And not only they will be passenger, they will reading devices like phones or Kindle because they are free, they don't have to drive. So this autonomous car or driverless car is opening a real problem or producing a real problem
几年后，每个人都会成为乘客。而且他们不仅是乘客，还会阅读手机或Kindle等设备，因为他们很空闲，不需要开车。所以这种自动驾驶汽车或无人驾驶汽车正在引发一个真正的问题，
which we psychologists will have to deal with. And I'm going to present a few type of solution or possible solution, which I did in my work in the Navy. One of them was artificial horizon. We do know that the reason motion sickness developed, it has to do with some type of conflict between the information the eyes get and the information that the vestibular information
这是我们心理学家必须处理的。我将介绍我在海军工作中采用的几种解决方案或可能的解决方案。其中之一是人工地平线。我们知道晕动症的发展与眼睛获取的信息和前庭信息之间的某种冲突有关，
or vestibular system. Which is in your ear? In our inner ear, yes. Right, right. Yes. and in the study I did with the TNO in the Netherlands, we were able to show that using artificial horizon, we could dramatically reduce the amount of motion sickness
或者说是前庭系统。是在你的耳朵里吗？在我们的内耳里，是的。对，对。是的。在我和荷兰TNO合作的研究中，我们能够证明，使用人工地平线，我们可以显著减少晕动症的程度，
and increase performance, that performance is becoming better as compared to people who did not have this artificial horizon which was kind of projected on the walls of the tilting room that we use. But this is some technical details. But what I really want to emphasize in this lecture that I'm going to give, which will be one of another two lectures,
并提高表现。与没有使用这种人工地平线的人相比，表现变得更好。这种人工地平线被投射在我们使用的倾斜房间的墙壁上。但这是一些技术细节。但我真正想在这次演讲中强调的是，这将是另外两场演讲之一，
but one of my talk will speak not so much on technical solution, but that we as psychologist has to examine the process of adaptation, because people do adapt to motion sickness, but we don't know enough about this process. And apparently it's not enough just to be exposed to the motion. We have to help them using various cognitive behavioral therapy approaches. And there is an interesting correlation now
但我的一场演讲不会过多谈论技术解决方案，而是强调我们作为心理学家必须审视适应过程，因为人们确实会适应晕动症，但我们对这个过程了解不够。显然，仅仅暴露在运动中是不够的。我们必须通过各种认知行为疗法来帮助他们。现在有一个有趣的关联，
between what I do in my clinical practice with people who are afraid from being sick, or afraid from vomiting, I'm doing gradual exposure to motion sickness. And it is possible that with this driverless car, we will need to do the same. So this is one of the area I'm going to talk in this conference, but then I will jump, if it's okay, with you, to another area which related to my main practice as a clinical psychologist. Okay, but before we get too far into that, a couple of questions about motion sickness. So you talked about an artificial horizon.
即我在临床实践中对那些害怕生病或害怕呕吐的人所做的工作，我正在进行晕动症的渐进式暴露疗法。很有可能，对于这种无人驾驶汽车，我们也需要这样做。所以这是我将在本次会议上讨论的领域之一，但如果可以的话，我想和您跳到与我作为临床心理学家的主要实践相关的另一个领域。好的，但在我们深入探讨之前，还有几个关于晕动症的问题。您提到了人工地平线。
So I'm in an autonomous car. There's a real horizon out there. So why does that not prevent me from getting motion sick? What's happening? Or if you just gave me a steering wheel and I thought I was in control, would I feel better? Well, that's a very interesting. You have two points here. Both of them are good.
我在一辆自动驾驶汽车里。外面有一个真实的地平线。那么为什么这不能阻止我晕车呢？发生了什么？或者如果你给我一个方向盘，让我觉得我在控制，我会感觉好些吗？嗯，这是一个非常有趣的问题。你提到了两点。它们都很好。
But let's go to the second one, which I was just trying in my, clinic in Israel, I wonder what happened if you have a wheel but you don't really control, you just play with it, like what I did with my child when he was some years ago. And apparently, we don't have a good research about it yet, but apparently it does help. So, you know, in this autonomous car, there's going to be some stages. At the beginning, we will still need the will, although it would not. really control the car. So I do suggest that people will kind of play with a useless will just to feel that they have perceived control. Regarding your previous question, it is true.
但让我们谈谈第二点，我刚才在以色列的诊所里尝试过，我想知道如果你有一个方向盘但你并没有真正控制它，只是玩弄它，就像我几年前和我的孩子做的那样，会发生什么。显然，我们还没有关于它的充分研究，但它似乎确实有帮助。所以，你知道，在这种自动驾驶汽车中，会有一些阶段。起初，我们仍然需要方向盘，尽管它并不能真正控制汽车。所以我建议人们可以玩弄一个无用的方向盘，只是为了感觉到他们有感知控制。关于你之前的问题，确实如此。
The main focus is that we need to give them a good visual reference. If the car manufacturer will be wise enough, they will do a big windows and that will be the best. But if you will notice in the diagram of how they prepare or plan those car. They are going to be like a room with many chairs facing each other, not facing the movement and a lot of screens. So people might not see the visual surrounding. And this is why I'm kind of, I think, that they will have to hear us,
重点是我们必须给他们一个良好的视觉参考。如果汽车制造商足够聪明，他们会设计大窗户，那将是最好的。但如果你注意到他们准备或规划这些汽车的图表，它们看起来像一个房间，里面有许多椅子面对面，而不是面对运动方向，还有很多屏幕。所以人们可能看不到视觉环境。这就是为什么我认为他们必须听取我们的意见，
We psychologists, our voice must be heard in these issues. Is that a problem so far with the cars that they're designing? Are you hearing that car sickness is an issue? Well, you see, everybody is now obsessed with the issue, shall they do accident or not? Right. And not enough about this issue. Well, there is, I should be more concrete.
我们心理学家的声音必须在这些问题上被听到。到目前为止，他们设计的汽车存在这个问题吗？您是否听说晕车是一个问题？嗯，你看，每个人现在都沉迷于这个问题，他们会发生事故吗？对。而对这个问题关注不够。嗯，有，我应该更具体一点。
Or a Mercedes-Benz is doing some research, and other companies are doing research. So it's not that they ignore. that they ignore it, but still the main focus is not exactly on this issue, I think. There is another issue I should mention. It's again important for psychologists. The issue of trust, we have to trust this computer that will drive us. Right. And it will be interesting to see what type of people will be kind of trusting it. No problem. And the other will sit anxious and anxiety. might produce even more sickness.
梅赛德斯-奔驰正在进行一些研究，其他公司也在进行研究。所以并不是他们忽视了，但我认为重点并不完全在这个问题上。我应该提到另一个问题。这对心理学家来说同样重要。信任问题，我们必须信任这台将驾驶我们的计算机。对。看看什么样的人会信任它将是一件有趣的事情。没问题。而其他人会感到焦虑，焦虑可能会产生更多的疾病。
So there are interesting questions here. So why is it that some people get seasick or car sick and others don't? That's again a good question. Some people thought it's related to the function of their vestibular system in the inner area. And apparently not. Everybody that has a functional vestibular system might get sick. in our Navy, my data show that 70% of the people get seasick if the sea is high enough. In the car, it might be a little bit less, it might be less,
所以这里有一些有趣的问题。那么为什么有些人会晕船或晕车，而另一些人不会呢？这又是一个好问题。有些人认为这与他们内耳前庭系统的功能有关。显然不是。每个拥有功能性前庭系统的人都可能生病。在我们的海军中，我的数据显示，如果海浪足够大，70%的人会晕船。在车里，可能会少一点，可能会少一些，
but again, if they will be reading and looking on certain devices, they will be apparently either not sick or they will have what they call sopite syndrome. Soapid syndrome is related to what I said about some type of lethargy, apathy, depression that we did show that emotion sickness does produce even without nausea. So that's produced. It's not something that you have before you get motion sick. It's when, after you become motion sick, you have this soapite syndrome. That's an interesting question. I studied with three of the leading people in this field. One is J.T. Reason from England. The other is Heston Grabeil from Florida. And the third is
但同样，如果他们一直在阅读和看某些设备，他们显然要么不会晕，要么会患上所谓的“索派特综合征”（sopite syndrome）。索派特综合征与我所说的某种嗜睡、冷漠、抑郁有关，我们证明了即使没有恶心，晕动症也会产生这些症状。所以它产生了。这不是你在晕动症之前就有的。这是在你晕动症之后，你才会有这种索派特综合征。这是一个有趣的问题。我和这个领域的三位领军人物一起研究过。一位是英国的J.T. Reason。另一位是佛罗里达的Heston Grabeil。第三位是
James Lackner in Brandeis University. They were all studying this soapite syndrome, and they say that sometimes it develops even without the symptoms of motion sickness. Like we can see it as a phenomena that might be developed without nausea and without vomiting. Interesting. So you talked a little bit about cognitive behavioral therapy as one way to counteract motion sickness. How exactly would that work?
布兰代斯大学的James Lackner。他们都在研究这种索派特综合征，他们说有时它甚至在没有晕动症症状的情况下也会发展。就像我们可以把它看作是一种可能在没有恶心和呕吐的情况下发展的现象。有趣。所以您谈到了一些关于认知行为疗法作为抵消晕动症的一种方法。这到底是如何工作的？
Well, in my studies, again, some earlier studies and some later, we trained a soldier or sailors with some simple cognitive behavioral techniques, or it could be either relaxation, either changing their cognition. And we show that people that did it and that people that had high self-control where by far they perform better than their counterparts or their other sailors that did not have self-control ability. We use the classical method of measuring self-control, and we were able to show that cognitive ability of self-control might be very useful. Now, I should mention here a very important.
嗯，在我的研究中，同样是一些早期的研究和一些后期的研究，我们用一些简单的认知行为技术训练士兵或水手，可以是放松，也可以是改变他们的认知。我们证明，那些这样做的人和那些具有高自我控制力的人，他们的表现远好于他们的同行或其他没有自我控制能力的水手。我们使用了测量自我控制的经典方法，我们能够证明自我控制的认知能力可能非常有用。现在，我应该在这里提到一个非常重要的
figure is named Dobby, James Dobby, who worked in the Naval Biodynamic Lab here in this country, and he just published a book about his, I am speaking about 40 years, I think he's working 50 years in the field, and he's not psychologist, but what he found, that in order to help pilots, sailors, and people that suffer for motion sickness, he uses cognitive behavior therapies. And there is another study that people did it in the sea just some years ago with very good results. So yes, we, you know, people in the field of cognitive behavioral therapy usually think that their job is to prevent drivers' rage or drivers' anger or, you know, anxiety or depression, I invite our colleague in the CBT to begin to prepare themselves to a new arena
人物，名叫多比（Dobby），詹姆斯·多比（James Dobby），他在这个国家的海军生物动力实验室工作，他刚刚出版了一本书，关于他的，我指的是40年，我想他在这个领域工作了50年，他不是心理学家，但他发现，为了帮助飞行员、水手和患有晕动症的人，他使用了认知行为疗法。还有另一项研究，人们几年前在海上做了同样的事情，效果非常好。所以是的，我们，你知道，认知行为疗法领域的人通常认为他们的工作是防止司机的愤怒或司机的焦虑或抑郁，我邀请我们在CBT的同事开始为自己准备一个新的领域，
that they should work, and this is how to help people at the cars. And more important, motion sickness is very much conditioned. Like if I'm driving in a car and in this car there is a smell. some type of smell that usually wouldn't bother me. This smell is kind of conditioned with the nausea. This is a phenomena we all know in psychology. We call condition taste aversion and conditioned smell aversion. So it is possible again that we might also test the role of odors
他们应该工作，这就是如何帮助车里的人。更重要的是，晕动症在很大程度上是条件反射的。比如如果我在车里开车，车里有一种气味。某种通常不会困扰我的气味。这种气味与恶心形成了条件反射。这是我们心理学中都知道的现象。我们称之为条件性味觉厌恶和条件性嗅觉厌恶。所以再次强调，我们也许可以测试气味的作用，
and maybe we can prevent this conditioning by using different odors at the first drive or the first voyage that people are doing. So you'd associate a good odor with feeling well. Exactly, exactly. But may I go to other field at the time? Like I began with the old ancient problem, but now I'm dealing a lot with the role of the Internet
也许我们可以通过在人们第一次驾驶或第一次航行时使用不同的气味来防止这种条件反射。所以你会把一种好的气味与感觉良好联系起来。完全正确，完全正确。但我可以谈谈其他领域吗？就像我从古老的旧问题开始，但现在我正在处理很多关于互联网的作用，
in helping people. And in fact, in psychology, there is two directions that the Internet took. One is to do what they call Skype therapy or online video conference. And this is mainly the relational people or the psychodynamic people that were said, hey, it's interesting to see what we can learn about therapy when we do it online. Is it the same therapy? Is it the same alliance that is produced in this online therapy?
在帮助人们方面。事实上，在心理学中，互联网采取了两个方向。一个是做所谓的Skype治疗或在线视频会议。这主要是关系派或心理动力学派的人说，嘿，看看我们在网上做治疗时能学到什么很有趣。这是同样的治疗吗？这种在线治疗中产生的联盟是一样的吗？
and I just published a book with Chaim Weinberg, a friend of mine, about online therapy. There is some books in this area, but our book is dealing with cases that we are doing it not only one-on-one, like classical psychotherapy, we are doing it with couples, with families, with groups, and with organizations. So this is the uniqueness of our book that we are dealing with. it, doing online therapy, and it produces very interesting questions. For example, now there's two people sitting in front of me, you and our technician, and suppose I want to see the interaction between the two of you. Now, the classical people just put the guy or the couple before the camera, before the computer, and we just see two faces. It's not what we want.
我刚刚和我的朋友海姆·温伯格（Chaim Weinberg）出版了一本书，关于在线治疗。这个领域有一些书，但我们的书处理的是我们不仅是一对一，像经典的心理治疗，我们还与夫妻、家庭、团体和组织一起做。所以这是我们书的独特性，我们正在处理它，进行在线治疗，它产生了非常有趣的问题。例如，现在有两个人坐在我面前，你和我们的技术员，假设我想看看你们两人之间的互动。现在，经典的人只是把那个人或那对夫妇放在摄像机前，放在电脑前，我们只看到两张脸。这不是我们想要的。
we want to see the full body we want to see the interaction between the couple what happens when the wife says something that bothers the male or vice versa we want to see their bodily
我们想看到全身，我们想看到夫妻之间的互动，当妻子说了什么让男性困扰的事情时会发生什么，反之亦然，我们想看到他们的身体
behavior so we did develop some new way that with the new cameras that can go from one to the other and the couple then
行为，所以我们确实开发了一些新的方法，利用新的摄像机可以从一个人转到另一个人，然后这对夫妇
can also see where I'm looking, although I'm in Israel. And the couple, let's say, in the United States, we found the cameras that could represent my head. And now my head is showing, the camera is looking on you, and now the camera is looking on our nice technician here. So I'm speaking about a lot of things that we are testing now regarding this online therapy.
也可以看到我在看哪里，尽管我在以色列。而这对夫妇，比如说在美国，我们找到了可以代表我头部的摄像机。现在我的头部显示，摄像机正在看着你，现在摄像机正在看着我们这里这位很好的技术员。所以我谈论的是我们现在正在测试的关于这种在线治疗的很多事情。
So is the therapist controlling the cameras? Exactly. And then the people who are the patients, they're able to see themselves at the same time or afterwards? How exactly does that work? Well, people can see themselves. That's another interesting question in this Skype and Zoom and all of the other programs. People can see themselves. And sometimes it's produced some too much people are too much self-aware.
所以是治疗师在控制摄像机吗？完全正确。然后作为病人的那些人，他们能够同时或事后看到自己吗？这到底是怎么工作的？嗯，人们可以看到自己。这是Skype和Zoom以及所有其他程序中的另一个有趣的问题。人们可以看到自己。有时它产生了一些太多的自我意识。
Right. But your question is very important. Yes, we found a way that the therapist from a distance can control the camera which exists in the couple's room. And in this way, it makes it somewhat more like a real therapy. You know, in couple therapy, we usually need to kind of approach the male and tell him, hey, please, count down. We might approach the female and tell her, could you? invite him in more. So we are like a conductor of orchestra and we cannot do it.
对。但你的问题非常重要。是的，我们找到了一种方法，让远处的治疗师可以控制这对夫妇房间里的摄像机。通过这种方式，它使它在某种程度上更像真正的治疗。你知道，在夫妻治疗中，我们通常需要接近男性并告诉他，嘿，请冷静下来。我们可能会接近女性并告诉她，你能邀请他更多地参与吗？所以我们就像管弦乐队的指挥，我们做不到。
Well, we couldn't do it till we developed this technique where we can really give the couple the feeling that we are either looking on one of them or the other. So that's one direction that we are doing with online therapy. But that's not enough. I think that we need not to, it's not enough to be happy that we are doing a good online therapy. What happens between one session to the other session? Usually in psychotherapy, psychotherapy is a wonderful experience. People love it.
嗯，在我们开发这种技术之前我们做不到，我们可以真正给这对夫妇一种感觉，即我们要么在看他们中的一个，要么在看另一个。所以这是我们在线治疗的一个方向。但这还不够。我认为我们不需要，仅仅因为我们在做很好的在线治疗而感到高兴是不够的。在一次会议和下一次会议之间发生了什么？通常在心理治疗中，心理治疗是一种美妙的体验。人们喜欢它。
If we are a good psychotherapist, the patient feels that you understand him. The patient feels that you are helping him to accept himself. The patient might feel some hope. It's a wonderful thing. But it's a fantasy that we can think that in one session a week or two sessions a week, we can really do a significant change. So we developed an application that is kind of accompanying the subject or the patient, all the week.
如果我们是一个好的心理治疗师，病人会觉得你理解他。病人会觉得你在帮助他接受自己。病人可能会感到一些希望。这是一件美妙的事情。但认为在一周一次或一周两次的会议中，我们真的能做出重大改变，这是一种幻想。所以我们开发了一个应用程序，它在整个星期都在陪伴着受试者或病人。
Suppose we were talking about, let's say, my arousal now, speaking in this conference, and I will come to my therapist and I say, I was a little bit too, I don't know, exhausted. And suppose the therapist say, listen, now and it's okay, you can take breath and you can kind of think differently, you know, cognitive.
假设我们正在谈论，比如说我现在的兴奋，在这次会议上发言，我会来到我的治疗师面前说，我有点太，我不知道，精疲力竭了。假设治疗师说，听着，现在没关系，你可以深呼吸，你可以换个角度思考，你知道，认知。
But that's not enough. What will happen when I'm going to be interviewed tomorrow to the CBS? It might happen again. Right. So our point is that we will, between session, we produced an application that remind me to do what we discussed. It could be some types of what we call in CBT homework, but it could also be some type of, some type of, hey, Arnon, why want you, this program kind of accompanies,
但这还不够。明天我接受CBS采访时会发生什么？它可能再次发生。对。所以我们的观点是，在会议之间，我们制作了一个应用程序，提醒我做我们讨论过的事情。它可以是我们在CBT中所说的家庭作业，但它也可以是某种，某种，嘿，阿农，为什么不，这个程序陪伴着，
I would say, why won't you share with me some of your dreams or some of the thoughts that you had in the middle of the week? So our idea is to produce, we produced application that is accompanying the subject between sessions. It also measures our, anxiety, our depression. So there is a constant measure of the patient's situation, patients' well-being, and that helps the therapist to be aware what's happening and if the
我会说，为什么不和我分享一些你的梦想或你在周中产生的一些想法呢？所以我们的想法是产生，我们制作了在会议之间陪伴受试者的应用程序。它还测量我们的焦虑、我们的抑郁。所以有一个对病人情况、病人幸福感的持续测量，这有助于治疗师了解正在发生什么，以及
therapy is going well or not. So how is it measuring these things? Is it like testing your skin conductance or your heart rate? or, I mean, what exactly is it doing? And you said it so that every day at 3 o'clock it reminds you, like now's the time for you to be mindful and deep, deep breathe and all those good things? Yes, reminder is, of course, one very important aspect.
治疗是否进展顺利。那么它是如何测量这些东西的？它是像测试你的皮肤电导或心率吗？或者，我的意思是，它到底在做什么？你说它每天3点提醒你，就像现在是你保持正念、深呼吸和所有那些好事情的时候了？是的，提醒当然是一个非常重要的方面。
We came from the biofeedback field. All of our, it's not only me, it's Dr. Yuvalodadad, and Dr. Gorinich, who is kind of developing this system. So we are very much aware of the psychophysiology and the sensor. But at this stage, we are more focusing really on some interaction between the patient and the therapist. And it's going automatically. The therapist does not have to be aware, hey, what happens to my patient who now in Tel Aviv? the system send him a message, a message that is designed with the therapist and the patient.
我们来自生物反馈领域。我们所有的，不仅仅是我，还有尤瓦尔·奥达德（Yuval Odad）博士和戈里尼奇（Gorinich）博士，他们正在开发这个系统。所以我们非常了解心理生理学和传感器。但在现阶段，我们更多地关注病人与治疗师之间的一些互动。它是自动进行的。治疗师不必意识到，嘿，我现在在特拉维夫的病人发生了什么？系统会给他发一条消息，一条与治疗师和病人共同设计的消息。
Let's say this week we are going to focus on your ability to think differently, on your ability to initiate more social activities. So coming back to your question, it's not mainly censors, although we have developed some ideas about sensors, but at this stage it is more verbal. So you think that's where psychotherapy is going, or is this going to be just an adjunct to traditional therapy? I think we psychologists are now divided to two companies, or no, two camps.
假设这周我们将专注于你换个角度思考的能力，专注于你发起更多社交活动的能力。所以回到你的问题，它主要不是传感器，尽管我们已经开发了一些关于传感器的想法，但在现阶段它更多是口头的。所以你认为这就是心理治疗的发展方向，还是这仅仅是传统治疗的辅助手段？我认为我们心理学家现在分为两个阵营，或者不，两个阵营。
There is the camp to say, this is not psychotherapy. We are not allowed to do it. The main issue in psychotherapy is the human interaction. And they say, completely don't do that. There is the other camp who say,
有一个阵营说，这不是心理治疗。我们不允许这样做。心理治疗的主要问题是人际互动。他们说，完全不要那样做。有另一个阵营说，
if it works, why won't we do it? In my clinic, we decided to combine the two camps and what we are doing is really, we are doing a lot of online therapy and coming back to your question, we are going there. No, the genie is out of the battle. Now, we could use it in a positive way or in negative way.
如果它有效，为什么我们不这样做呢？在我的诊所，我们决定结合这两个阵营，我们正在做的是，我们确实在做大量的在线治疗，回到你的问题，我们正在走向那里。不，精灵已经从瓶子里出来了。现在，我们可以以积极的方式或消极的方式使用它。
I've just been in New York and I've seen Aladdin. And we could see that there was happy end there, and I do hope that in our case, there will also be some happy end, namely that psychotherapy can really advance using both online video conference and online applications that can enhance the therapy. Well, it sounds like you're doing a lot of really interesting work in your clinic. I'm very happy that you were able to join us today and appreciate you're taking the time
我刚在纽约看过《阿拉丁》。我们可以看到那里有一个幸福的结局，我确实希望在我们的案例中，也会有一些幸福的结局，即心理治疗可以通过使用在线视频会议和可以加强治疗的在线应用程序真正取得进步。嗯，听起来你在你的诊所做了很多非常有趣的工作。我很高兴你今天能加入我们，并感谢你抽出时间，
and we'll keep an eye on your work. I'm sure people who experience things like sea sickness and car sickness are going to be very concerned as we have more and more of these autonomous cars out there. So I hope that your work is able to save those of us who get a little queasy from experiencing that. Well, thank you. And if people are interested, our work will be published in a site called Internet Psychology. Sorry, internetpsychotherapy.competreeperop.com.com. Great. That's good to know. We can include that in our notes.
我们会关注你的工作。我相信那些经历过晕船和晕车的人会非常担心，因为我们外面有越来越多的自动驾驶汽车。所以我希望你的工作能够拯救我们这些容易感到恶心的人。嗯，谢谢。如果人们感兴趣，我们的工作将发表在一个名为“互联网心理学”的网站上。抱歉，internetpsychotherapy.com。太好了。很高兴知道这一点。我们可以把它包含在我们的笔记中。
Before we go, I just wanted to remind our listeners that we at Speaking of Psychology want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. It really helps. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other informative podcasts such as APA Journal's dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes. about the practice of psychology.
在结束之前，我只想提醒我们的听众，我们《心理学谈话》希望听到你们的声音。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，所有单词连在一起，点 org。请在iTunes上给我们评分。这真的很有帮助。 《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他信息丰富的播客，例如APA期刊关于新心理学研究的对话和关于心理学实践的进度记录。
You can find all our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.sperengofpsychology.org, and listen to more episodes. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。谢谢。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。